dr anthony fauci joins us he's in
washington right now and he is the
director of the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases and a
member of the white house coronavirus
task force
good morning to you dr fauci good to see
you it seems like a good day we're
hearing news of a second vaccine
possibly being authorized by the end of
the week 95 percent
um effective which is really exciting so
what do you think it's going to take now
to have a real impact to slow the spread
of this virus with two
possibilities now on the market
well what we're going to see gail is an
increase in the number of people who
ultimately get vaccinated when you reach
a certain percentage of the population
to get vaccinated
you're going to really have an important
and profound impact on the dynamics of
the outbreak
so it's going to take a few months to do
that you know the first level of people
are the health care providers and those
who are for example in nursing homes and
long
long term facilities and then after that
you're going to start seeing
other priorities coming i would imagine
by the time we get
to let's say march end of march
beginning of april we will have people
who are in the general population
that are not in any particular priority
groups and we
hope that the overwhelming percentage of
the population will accept the vaccine
if we do that
we will get a veil or an umbrella of
herd immunity over the population that
would dramatically diminish the dynamics
of the outbreak when we do that
then that would be the end of the of
this outbreak so it's going to take
months to do
but we certainly are on the right track
we hope so too we keep hearing
you need at least 70 of herd immunity to
be really effective what's the biggest
challenge do you think in all of us
getting there
well the challenge is the acceptance on
the part of various elements in our
society
you know particularly and we're working
very hard minority
populations understandably have somewhat
of a skepticism i've been out there my
colleagues have been out there
trying to outreach to the to this group
of individuals
and explain to them the things that make
them skeptical
or for example the speed with which this
has happened
that's a really good thing gail because
the speed is a reflection
of the extraordinary scientific advances
in vaccine platform technology that
allowed us to get here quickly
and also the enormous investment that
has been made
in developing and and and producing
doses of vaccine so that they're ready
when the fda makes that decision that's
exactly what happened
with pfizer and that is what is going to
happen with modena
and i'm wondering how you're feeling
during this time dr fauci as you see the
vaccine roll out because we had a moment
at the table the other day we actually
thought
it we got emotional looking at the
trucks rolling out and you've been
working on this most of the year
so i wonder what this is like for you to
be here at this place
at this time well
it's an extraordinary feeling gail it's
a very positive feeling
you know as i've also even mentioned to
my own family my wife
is that as wonderful as this is because
it's been
you know an extraordinary manifestation
of the fruits of science done in a very
rapid way
it's also bittersweet because you know
the other day at the
time that the vaccine was first rolled
out and put into someone's arm
we reached the 300 000 death yes
in the united states from this virus so
you know
we should celebrate the fact that the
science has come through
but it is not over yet we have a ways to
go
we have to abide by the public health
measures that we talk about all the time
this is not going to just turn around
overnight we have a ways to go and
public health measures
is the bridge to get to the vaccine
which is going to get us out of this
all right dr fauci thank you very much
and before we go are you on a couchy
not really deal that's what i'm getting
you for christmas
about you on a couchy all right all
right thank you sorry thanks gail
great to be with you i'll give you one
of those i know he wants one of those i
love that we can laugh a little bit and
smile in a different way
i feel that too such a hopeful moment
it's just
full of hopeful details that vaccine is
coming and one of the first people who
got the shot there at uc davis happens
to be my brother-in-law jamie tur
why didn't you get it he is an icu
coveted doctor there at uc davis and i
had not put two and two together
that that was the hospital where david
was reporting and my brother-in-law
we got the video last night that's
really cool he's the first member of the
expensive feeling
family to get it he's really great side
effects those side effects
uh and uh he's raring to go i love
david's piece though
how he took us from point a to point b
all the way to z
do you see them actually getting the
shot and i i don't think we can
emphasize enough how important this is
yes and how hopeful that it is and it's
great to see how excited everybody in
the hospital was
it's protection and relief we're feeling
it big time